how's it going guys my name is dumb and
today I want to show you how to use
iconography on your websites or your web
applications using the iron-icons
library so basically iron-icons
is a free and open source icon set
containing over 700 icons for both the
iOS and material designer style so you
can choose one of these two cells and
use it for your icons so it actually
comes packaged with the ionic framework
itself but you can use it without the
ionic framework so we're going to learn
how to do that in this video so the
first thing to do is to actually install
the icon set in your HTML file so we can
go to iron-icons com forward slash usage
and then scroll down to the installation
section we can now copy and paste this
script tag inside our HTML file so for
this far right here it looks like this
we can just go down here and paste it
right below the finishing sorry the end
of the body tag so now we have the icon
set installed inside the HTML file we
can now use it very simply okay so the
way this works is that each icon has its
own web component so to use an icon
below the h1 tag we can create a new tag
it'll be the I on - icon tag so this is
a custom web component for the iron icon
framework sorry the iron icon icon set
or library okay so to specify what icon
you want you can do so using the name
attribute so inside here we're going to
type out a name equal to an empty string
for now we're going to fill this with a
prefix of the design to use followed by
the actual icon name so back to the iron
icons where
site we can go over to the icon section
and then choose one of these icons let's
choose the apps icon as an example right
so if I choose this we get the name of
the icon
it's called apps so I can simply put
apps inside here so if you're using the
iron-icons icon set with the ionic
framework you can simply do this and
you're done the design style is going to
automatically be chosen based on the the
OS of the device that's running on but
in this video we're looking at using it
without the ionic framework so we have
to actually specify the type of design
to use so we have we have the material
design or the iOS design or style so we
can see the difference between these two
designs right here so to specify the
actual design style we can prefix it
with either MD or iOS so for example
let's talk about MD - apps just like
that so now this will generate an SVG of
the apps icon for a material design so I
can save this and refresh my browser and
we get this right here an SVG for the
apps icon in material design okay
perfect so we can simply change this to
iOS to achieve the iOS version of that
apps icon I can save this and refresh
and we get this right here okay so
pretty cool to actually customize this
size and the color of these icons we can
do so using a CSS or in the case of the
the size we can use an attribute so for
example I can say space and say size is
equal to large to create a large icon I
can save this and refresh and we get a
bigger icon right
okay so to actually do that using CSS
it's quite straightforward as well I'll
get rid of this and go inside a new
style tag and we're gonna target every
iron icon element inside the web page so
we'll type our iron and - icon inside
here we can put a font size property so
we can say font size and the
documentation recommends you use font
sizes in multiples of eight so for
example eight 16 32 or 64 and so on so
let's say 64 pixels for this particular
size I can save this and refresh and we
get a much larger icon okay perfect
we can also customize the color by using
the CSS color property color and then
blue okay I can save this and refresh
and now we get this right here and
that's how you can use the iron icons
framework or sorry the our icons library
to achieve iconography inside your
websites or your web applications
alright thanks for watching and I'll see
you later